this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video ah so hello and
welcome to yet another episode of
biographics I'm your interim host Carl
Smallwood that's car with a K and
Smallwood spelled the way it sounds s m
a w l w o d and today we're talking
about Queen Elizabeth I Queen of
England's golden age and as with all the
videos here on biographics this one is
based on original script submitted To Us
by a member of our writing team that
member of the writing team today being
Ben Adelman you can follow them at the
social media links below which are found
alongside my own as well as all those
other bells and whistles YouTubers like
to ask you to click that improve
analytics like the like button that
little bell leave a comment with
feedback suggestions and ideas for
future videos and subscribe for more
videos like this normally I'd ask at the
end but I've been told by you know the
Big Wigs behind the scenes the early in
the video I asked people to do that the
more likely those things are to
happen during the 16th century England
women were treated as little more than
property yeah things kind of suck back
then and most men particularly powerful
men believe that women were irrational
overly emotional and generally unfit to
handle their own Affairs much less rule
an entire country there's definitely not
any men out there like that therefore
when Elizabeth I was crowned Queen of
England in 1558 few believe she had the
right temperament and intelligence to
handle the stresses of personally
running an entire country as monarchs in
those days did the best they could have
hoped for they said was that she would
marry a man who would rule in her name
and secure the succession by having
children preferably boys for obvious
reasons but Elizabeth would prove all of
her naysayers wrong for over 40 years
she and her group of talented advisers
would oversee what has been called
England's golden age or more simply the
Elizabeth and era a time of stability
and relative Prosperity at a time when
most of Europe was being torn apart by
Eternal strife and War in order to make
sure no one took power from her she
refused to marry claiming that instead
she was married to the nation initially
causing widespread conation amongst her
many subjects the decision would
eventually endear her to the English
people who revered her as the Virgin
Queen sent down from High by God himself
to defend England and the Protestant
religion against the powerful forces of
Catholic Europe who sought to destroy
them in particular Spain the Elizabethan
age would prove to be the height of the
English Renaissance as a new
appreciation for the Arts music and
particularly theater flourished during
Elizabeth's Reign this is not to say
that things are perfect by any means the
income inequality between rich and poor
was as lopid as it had ever been and
Elizabeth herself suffered from numerous
flaws including vanity jealousy and
paranoia that drove the people around
her
[Music]
mad for most of the first part of her
life Elizabeth found herself at the
center of all sorts of Court Intrigue
and plots that would put her life in
danger because of her proximity to the
throne of England she was born on
September 7th 1533 the daughter of the
famed King Henry VII and his second wife
Anberlin both parents were disappointed
with her sex she was supposed to be a
boy the long awaited heir to the throne
that was after all one of the main
reasons that Henry had divorced his
first wife Catherine of aragan and I've
already covered King Henry VII in the
previous biographic videos which if it's
been edited and he's up on the site will
be here somewhere link down below and
he'd married Anne to like you know try
and bear him a son breaking off from the
Catholic church in the process a like
you know the results of which can still
be felt to this day before she turned
just 3 years old the young princess's
life was fever altered when her mother
was convicted of being an adulterous and
beheaded a scandal that most historians
today view as little better than
judicial murder while Henry quickly
moved on marrying Jane Seymour and
finally getting a son Edward Elizabeth
was declared to be a bastard since her
parents marriage had been invalidator
and even at a young age Elizabeth was
known as being quite perceptive asking
of her caretakers why they suddenly
stopped calling her princess in favor of
Lady Elizabeth and it can't have been an
easy childhood for Elizabeth considering
she had a dead mother and a father who
was obsessed with the idea of having a
male Heir only the king's Sixth and
final Queen Katherine par made any
serious attempt to parent her it could
be argued that she raised herself
although she did have the benefit of
being a child of a monarch so she
received an education that was as fine
as any prince in Europe and she quickly
impressed her teachers with her
intelligence she also read extensively
and had at least some fluency in eight
other languages besides The King's
English after King Henry died in 1547
Elizabeth Peril only grew as Admiral
Thomas Seymour the new king's uncle came
up with a scheme to marry her in order
to increase his own power whether
Elizabeth wanted to marry him or not did
not seem to be a consideration and there
is considerable historical evidence that
Seymour engaged in to put it lightly and
to not get demonetized inappropriate
behavior with the teenager possibly in
an attempt to groom her into allowing
him to have sex with her and be an air
his scheme thankfully fell apart in 1549
was arrested and beheaded for treason
Elizabeth though interrogated
extensively would admit to nothing wrong
in 1553 after Edward died without an
heir the crown passed to Elizabeth her
sister Mary a devout Catholic Mary
announced her intentions to return
England to the papal F marrying Philip
of Spain another devouted follower of
the old religion in 1554 what public
support Mary may have had basically
evaporated overnight following the
marriage and Mary made things worse by
trying to force the issue burning some
300 Protestants at the akake for heresy
during her Reign earning her the
nickname Bloody Mary the hopes of the
English Protestants were pinned firmly
on Elizabeth now air to the throne and
she was accused being of aent of a
number of plots to depose Mary in favor
of her despite the fact it was unlikely
she'd ever been directly involved with
any of them the paranoid Mary locked up
her sister in the Tower of London and
there was a lot of Talk Amongst her
advisers about putting Elizabeth on
trial and executing her though this
never really came to
fruition
fortunately for Elizabeth cooler heads
prevailed and thus her life was spared
as a result when Mary died in 1558
having borne no children Elizabeth at
just age 25 was crowned the Queen of
England her government faced a number of
important issues including religious
matters the crown being deeply in debt
as well as the everpresent question of
who would succeed Elizabeth as Monarch
if something happened to her quite an
appropriate question given how many
kings and queens have died in the last
two decades most of the powerful men
around her including Parliament and the
privy Council encouraged her to find a
husband who and I quote might relieve
her of those labors which are fit only
for men in other words a man who would
rule the country in her name while she
focused on the proper womanly duties of
bearing children that would one day wear
the crown themselves and this raised the
number of issues like because who should
she choose there was no shortage of
foreign princes and monarchs aspiring to
marry her at one point there were
ambassadors from a dozen different
countries vying for a handin marriage
however as shown by by the public outcry
over Mary's Spanish husband England was
quite an insular xenophobic place at the
time and many were less than
enthusiastic by the idea of a foreigner
ruling over them particularly a Catholic
one so the other option was well marry
an Englishman and there was no shortage
of those clamming for a hand as well and
if she was going to choose any of them
it probably would have been Robert
Dudley the Earl of Leicester the two had
been firm friends since childhood and
for most of her Reign he was her
favorite courtier insisting on him
attending to her as much as possible but
Dudley faced the problem that of
Elizabeth subjects would face if they
were to marry her rival caught factions
jealous of his influence over her
scheming to undermine him at every
possible turn he was accused of all
sorts of Nefarious plots including that
he had his own wife murdered in order to
try and marry the queen an allegation
that doggedly pursued him for centuries
after his death there have been many
reasons put forward as to why the queen
never chose to marry there's been
supposition that she had a mental
aversion to the very concept of marriage
and when your dad is King Henry VII yeah
that tracks because who wouldn't
associate marriage with danger after
having him for a parent others have said
that she may have been afraid of
childbirth which was a perilous
procedure in those days again yeah
others have argued that she may have
been incapable of having children or
perhaps suffered from any number of
gynecological issues that would make
having sex too painful to contemplate or
render her infertile but the most likely
reason that she refused to marry is
simply that she just didn't want to give
up the power she'd been entrusted with
that she believed God had bestowed upon
her she would be expected to be
subservient and submissive to her
husband queen or not and if she gave
birth to her son she could expect
pressure to be put on her to abdicate in
favor of him or even that she might be
forcibly deposed in favor of him so I
know everyone out there was Finding what
I was saying very very interesting which
T take a word from today's sponsor which
means I need my business aner and of
course my behind the scenes co-hosts and
Brad and Nisha who is today's sponsor
and today's video is sponsored by
Squarespace ah the space of square so I
feel like I'm a pretty old hat at this
by now so Squarespace is is a service
that lets you make websites well
Squarespace allows entrepreneurs to
easily create and customize their own
websites it's suitable from beginners to
professionals which you know that covers
us we NE the beginnner not professionals
we're somewhere in the middle beginner
Falls don't try and do that again okay
you're not you're not Barney Stinson but
Squarespace uh you can use it to blog
you can engage with your audience and
you can also sell products content or
time or just advertise your business of
course yes you might be thinking well I
don't have a business to advertise well
do you have a social media platform
that's advertising you and don't you
hate that the social media profile has
to look the way the social media site
wants it to wouldn't you like to go back
to the Myspace days and customize it to
be in tune with your personality and
tell people who you really are at a
glance you can do that with Squarespace
you can even have it play music when
people arrive if you really want to so
if you do want to make a website using
Squarespace you can I can't stop looking
at the snoo no one can that's why we
have it Brad it's really good it's good
for audience retention so like we looked
at the analytics and say 1% more people
watch these spots if I'm you know
petting my antier I said 30% more people
are really weirded out but it's worth it
so if you do want to use Squarespace to
make a website you can look through
their vast array of templates and
customize them to you're liking using
the tried and true method of dragging
and dropping and I love dragging and
dropping yeah Squarespace have made
their own engine which allows you to
drag and drop things wherever you want
on the website uh so you can even do
this with the templates you can load up
a template and then move things around
your hearts can cuz you know what not
everyone's as creative as they think
they are everyone needs that little bit
of help don't know like oh I like this
I'll change the color and the font and
add an antier and a PNG ooh what font
should I pick comic Sands that'll do
well if you like to use comic Sands you
can and you can use it on your website
to do a variety of different things you
could set up a course and teach people
yeah and even charge for your time can
you imagine would you trust any c from
someone who picked Comics he's like
those things in like graphic design is
my passion it's like a clip art
frog yes so you can create a course and
you can charge for your time whether
that be a one times fee or a
subscription mhm you can also blog you
can and again people might think well I
don't want to blog do you have a social
media profile that's a micro blog that
is a Blog isn't it like do you hate
being limited to 280 characters so
basically anything you can do with a
website you can do on Squarespace MH
including perhaps one of the most
important ones for Content creators
which is analytics analytics online are
king and the idea is to have them all
your finger ticks is one that is
incredibly useful and more website
should make them easily available to
anyone using them and it annoys me when
they don't I need to make you a t-shirt
that says analytics AR they are so good
like you know the analytics for this
like you said people love it when we
talk to the anti here so thank you to
today's sponsor Squarespace check out
Squarespace at squarespace.com
biographics for 10% off your first
purchase of a website slain using the
code biographics and as he customary
with sponsor spots here at biographics
let's end on a bonus fact not found
anywhere else in the video so guys did
you know there was once a man who saved
himself from a volcanic explosion with
pee and
crime no they're two very different
things so one of the few people to
survive the 1902 eruption of the
appropriately named Mount peely I hope I
pronouncing that correctly was a guy
called ludgar Sybaris and he was a
person who' been arrested and was in a
jail cell when the volcano erupted and
he was one of the few people to have
survived that eruption due to the very
thick walls of the cell and a judici
application of his own P which he threw
at the window to block out the hot ash
and to cool themselves down and there is
a picture of them out there from the SW
and they they they look metal they got
burnt they got real burnt they got it
real bad but they survived thanks to
crying and
pee single or married Elizabeth could
not rule England by herself and she
assembled around her a group of devisers
that were among the most talented men in
England the Envy of the courts around
Europe Europe this included William
seong Baron berley who was a principal
adviser for most of her Reign one of her
closest confidants another important
figure were Sir Francis wallingham who
built a formidable intelligence network
of spies and informants that stretched
all the way across Europe as well as
serving as a key policy maker Elizabeth
government differed from that of her
father who was known for turning on his
ministers when they lost his temper even
when she quarreled with them the queen
was unfailingly loyal to the men closest
to her and they rewarded this loyalty by
serving her Faithfully for decades
Elizabeth's Court like those of most
Renaissance monarchs was expensive to
upkeep this may seem initially like a
matter of Simply Having expensive taste
Elizabeth for example had a collection
of some 3,000 dresses in her wardrobe
and reportedly had a new pair of shoes
made for her each and every week but it
was also a function of State in an age
when many common people were still
illiterate the best way to project the
power and Majesty of the Queen's
government was to Simply flaunt its
resources which include expensive
clothes jewelry Sumptuous Banquets and
fabulously decorated palaces that said
Elizabeth was as diligent an accountant
as her grandfather Henry iith and strove
to live within her means as much as
possible her being a queen those means
were quite extravagant but you know what
we mean she did not undertake extensive
building programs like her father and in
terms of foreign policy worked very hard
to avoid England going to war which had
always been the quickest way to drain
the coffers of the state when it came to
religious policy on the other hand
Elizabeth immediately overturned her
sister's attempts to catholici the
country reestablishing the Church of
England with herself serving as the
Supreme governor personally Elizabeth
favored a policy of Toleration instead
of force compliance there were no Mass
burnings of Heretics during her rule she
also sought to check what she saw as the
excesses of some of the more extreme
Protestant sex including the Puritans
one of the reasons theater plays
actually thrived under Elizabeth was her
overruling of Puritan attempts to have
them banned for being too sinful however
the situation changed in 1570 when Pope
Pas I issued a ball excommunicating
Elizabeth and her ministers declaring
that it was the duty of any good
Catholic to overthrow the her IC
Pretender and restore the country to the
true Faith despite the fact that most
Catholics in England remain loyal to
their Queen the bll provided the impetus
needed for the Hardline Protestants in
Elizabeth government to persecute
Catholics particularly in light of
several plots undertaken in the 1570s
and 80s to assassinate the queen most of
these plots center around Mary Stewart
Queen of the Scots who had been forced
to abdicate the throne of Scotland in
1567 as she was accused of involvement
with the murder of her husband lot
darnley Mary was the first cousin once
removed of Elizabeth giving her a pretty
strong claim to the English crown and
many Catholics both in England and
abroad viewed her as the rightful Queen
Elizabeth was nothing if not Paran noyed
about her Safety and Security on the
throne so she had Mary put under house
arest for nearly two decades despite the
urging of her ministers she refused to
execute her cousin since Royal Blood was
still supposed to be sacred chopping the
head off a fellow Monarch deposed or not
was just not the done thing back then
something her father never listened to
but hey ho she was finally persuaded to
execute her cousin in 1587 to remove her
as a threat following the exposure of
yet another assassination plot by this
point however an even bigger threat was
looming from outside the country setting
up a showdown between Elizabeth and the
most powerful Monarch in Christendom
Spain the kings of Spain were known as
the most Catholic of majesties and
Philip II was no exception from his
Palace in Madrid Philip oversaw a huge
Empire that stretched around the world
the first one ex said that the Sun never
set upon the vast quantities of gold and
other treasure being shipped to Spain
from colonies in America and Asia Ena
Philip to build a huge Army and Navy and
in 1580 he added the kingdom of Portugal
to his domains adding even more
territory and wealth Philip had once
been one of many suitors for Elizabeth
hand in marriage when she first became
Queen though apparently he was privately
relieved when she turned him down
Elizabeth was supposedly not a loer now
however he believed that it was his
Christian duty to return England to the
Catholic faith by any means necessary
and to do it he built a large Fleet of
ships known to history as the Spanish
Armada when said Armada set sail in May
1588 his mission was to sail through the
English Channel to the Spanish
controlled Netherlands where a large
army under the Duke of Palmer waited to
be escorted across to England there they
would invade depose Elizabeth and then
Philip could install a Catholic on the
throne to replace her and if Palmer's
Army got to shore it was unlikely that
England's own Force could have done
anything to stop them the English army
at this time was small poorly trained
and very underere equipped if england
and by extension Elizabeth were to be
saved the Armada had to be stopped at
Sea fortunately for decades prior
England had steadily built up her royal
Navy in an attempt to become a seafaring
power now it was time to put this power
to the test the English fleet was under
the command of Admiral Lord Howard but
most tactical decisions were made by the
more famous s Francis Drake the foremost
of England's Sea Dogs Drake had
circumnavigated the globe many times and
was famous for attacking and plundering
many Spanish treasure ships sh and
settlements in the new world for which
he was derived as a pirate by the
Spanish but loued as a hero by the
English in order to face down the Armada
Drake and Howard relied on a recent
shift in ship design and Naval tactics
specifically up to this point Naval
battles were primarily fought with large
slow ships containing lots of soldiers
the Cannons on board were designed to be
fired once and then the action would
shift to hand-to-hand boarding actions
English ships at this time though were
smaller faster and far more maneuverable
with cannons designed to be fired
repeatedly in order to sync enemy vels
before they could get close enough to
board them after two inconclusive
engagements in the English Channel the
decisive battle came off the coast of
grev lines in Flanders on August 8th the
night before the English sent out eight
fire ships abandoned ships that have
been loaded with gunpowder sulfur tar
and Pitch set on fire and then set a
drift to float towards the Spanish ships
at anchor in order to keep them from
being set a blaze many of the Spanish
ships cut their anchor chains and
Scattered breaking up the defensive
formation the next day the English set
upon the peace meal Spanish hits which
were shredded by gunfire the mder was
forced to sail all the way around the
British Isles in order to escape the
English ships and return to Spain many
of them wrecked by storms on their way
home the men on board either drowned or
killed by locals on Shore the defeat of
the Armada was a huge blow for the
Spanish with them losing almost a third
of their entire naval fleet which
amounted to about 40 or 50 ships in
regards to the number of men they lost
numbers range as high as 20,000
conversely the English lost only about
2500 men largely to disease and the only
ships they lost was the ones that they
deliberately set on fire and floated
towards the Spanish with the intent of
exploding them
[Music]
anyway even though much of the advantage
gained by defeating the Armada was lost
the very next year when Drake led a
similar disastrous Expedition known as
the English Armada the event was still
seen as a Triumph for Elizabeth and
England as a whole for the English it
was a sign of God's Divine favor and
that the queen had defended their
country and their faith from a wouldbe
Invader the war between Spain and
England would rage until 16004 within
England Elizabeth now had almost Divine
status in the minds of the common people
she had always been popular with the
people but now she was an otherworldly
presence a cult of personality around
her that had been compared to the Virgin
Mary which made sense considering she
was also known as the Virgin Queen now
if anyone curious about how accurate
that title was many have speculated on
whether or not she actually was a virgin
as she claimed or did she have any
secretly aons with many of the handsome
male courtiers that she gathered around
her and the answer according to
historians at least is that she probably
didn't let anyone into her bed and thus
died a urgin she knew better than anyone
else that the risks to her reputation
were too great for such frivolous
encounters she had to serve England of
course besides considering that like
most monarchs of the period Elizabeth
was never really truly alone and
constantly attended by servants and
courtiers and if she had engaged in an
affair with anyone people would have
found out about it sooner or later and
left records of it that was just the Dum
thing Elizabeth Reign is viewed as a
golden age in English History at a time
when the rest of Europe was being torn
apart by Wars of religion Elizabeth gave
her people over four Decades of stable
government and economic Prosperity a
welcome change from the eotic reign of
her father and their siblings the Arts
especially theater thrived during this
period Elizabeth personally sponsoring
her own troop of actors the Queen's
players and among the playwrights who
have performed for her was The Bard
himself William Shakespeare things
weren't always great however the
economic Prosperity didn't extend to
many of the country his poorest citizens
who were always the hardest hit during
poor harvests or times of plague in the
past these Poor Unfortunate Souls would
have been helped by The Many religious
houses the monasteries and such but
those have been dissolved in the 1530s
By Elizabeth's father and now many of
the poor fill the streets of cities like
London literally starving to death in
the gutter which yeah not great and
speaking of
which meanwhile Elizabeth wasn't exactly
the greatest Monarch to work for and she
had a fearsome Infamous temper that
rivaled that of her own father and was
prone to insulting and belittling even
her closest advisor when a night though
she famously died a virgin Elizabeth
took to surrounding herself with young
courtiers who expects to flirt with her
and tell her she was the most beautiful
woman in all of England even as she
tried to hide the signs of advancing age
by donning wigs and caking her face and
increasing amounts of Cosmetics to
whiten her skin for anyone curious it
took her a report of 2 hours to get
ready each and every morning she greatly
enjoyed watching men fighting for her
favor was notoriously jealous of other
women few wives were ever permitted at
court and when relatives got secretly
married without permission she was
liable to throw them in jail still when
she died in 16003 people recognized that
an end of an era had come few people
could remember what life was like
without her she had ruled England for 44
years at the time only Henry III and
Edward III had worn the crown for longer
her death also marked the end of the two
to Dynasty that had begun with her
grandfather in 1485 and it turns out
that all the teeth nashing about the
lion succession was was kind of
pointless because in the last years of
her life Elizabeth ministers had
secretly been writing to the King of
Scotland Mary Stewart's son James to
smooth way for a peaceful transition
when Elizabeth died ever since the two
countries have been ruled by one Monarch
and a century later we formly fused
together into one single super Nation
Great Britain at least until we mess
that one up and as the country descended
into religious turmoil and growing
disputes between King and parament that
would eventually erupt into Civil War
people look back on the Elizabethan era
with fond Nostalgia Elizabeth was
Gloriana or good Queen Bess portraits of
her appeared everywhere and even today
she ranks in the upper echelon of
English and British monarchs but
Elizabeth was above all a Survivor a
woman in a man's world The Unwanted and
unappreciated daughter of royalty who
outlasted her enemies and assured her
place in history through a combination
of luck endurance and skill few monarchs
prior or since have been more loved by
the people of England and it's unlikely
that we'll see many like her
again yeah if you found this video to be
entertaining informative and educational
you can you know let the author of the
piece Ben and know at the social media
links below mine are down there too as
are the other channels I host including
Wiki weekends with my friend Lucas and
faf with car small which I run um with
my friends behind the scenes you might
have seen them appearing in the sponsor
spots for some of these videos otherwise
I hope everybody enjoyed this video goes
out there has a great day like comment
subscribe all that good stuff and as
always have the day you all
deserve as
well
so the reason I have this is because uh
Americans don't know um like I think I
made a video a few years ago I wrote a
script at least for a video about the
Queen of England who was like you know
Elizabeth II at the time not needing a
passport and the reason for that is
because it says in your passport here
like a passport is just um a basically
just a formal request from the Monarch
to you know enter the foreign country so
it says in my password Here her
Britannic Majesty his secretary of state
request and requires In The Name Of Her
Majesty all those to whom it may concern
to allow the bearer of this past freely
without let or hindrance and to afford
the bearer such assistances and
protection as may be necessary and
because this is basically just a request
from the Monarch to travel to a foreign
Nation the queen doesn't need a passport
but I had to get a new passport um right
around the time the queen died so I
might have probably one of like the
rarer kinds of British passport that you
can have which is a blue passport that
we got because of brexit which sucks ass
but it's a blue passport that was um
issued after the queen died but still
says her majesty instead of his majesty
so I think I might have got like the
very last production run of passports
that still say her majesty instead of
his majesty in them so yeah so I'm stuck
with that for another 10 years oh yeah I
forget it's great as well because
obviously I passports after I you know
it's a celebration of the region in
which um uh you know you're going to too
and I love that the English passport
has has seagulls in it which I don't
know I don't know why British passport
has a Seagle in it like it makes me
really know about the Scottish one I
guess I can show that off yeah so you
see maybe there's a picture here but
yeah um the English like um like animal
that we have to like represent England
is a lion wearing a crown but Scotland
have just got one over on us cuz they
picked a unicorn they picked like we
even know that was an option like whales
have got dragons and like Island's got
like you know the some man wearing a
popack f snakes out of a staff we kind
of got short Chang in that one didn't we
either way cheers everybody go out there
and have the day you all
[Music]
deserve